Katie Holmes and daughter Suri are too  cute courtside the 38 year old actress  and her 11 year old attended the Knicks  versus the Oklahoma City Thunder game in  NYC on Saturday night where they were  seen smiling snuggling and sharing a few  big laughs  throughout the star-studded event Chris  Rock Michael J Fox Ansel Elgort and  Lindsay Lohan were among several celebs  at the game I was really excited  the mommy daughter duo kept things  casual for their night out Surry and a  light pink ladybug print puffy coat in  leggings while mom Katy rocked a  button-down printed dress tights and  burgundy knee-high boots for the outing  it was really a lot of fun  you